we have predators on our streets how can
he really be a progressive
and want to lock these people up and i'd
say lock the sobs up
increase the penalties increase them i
put the son of a gun in jail
put them to death
i wish i could say that hate began with
donald trump will end with him
it didn't and it won't get the [__] down
get the [__] over
during a week of protests looting and
violence ignited by the murder of george
floyd by a minneapolis police officer
joe biden pledged his support for
meaningful criminal justice reform
and doing more to prevent the
mistreatment of african americans by
cops
i call on the congress to act this month
on measures that will be the first step
in this direction starting with real
police
reform while biden deserves praise for
getting behind vital reforms as he
campaigns for president in 2020
it's worth remembering that the former
senator from delaware is partly
responsible for some of the worst
aspects of today's criminal justice
system it doesn't matter whether or not
they're the victims of society the end
result is they're about to
knock my mother on the head with a lead
pipe shoot my sister
beat up my wife take on my sons
so i don't want to ask what made them do
this
they must be taken off the street
there are other measures to stop
transferring weapons of war to police
forces improve oversight and
accountability
let the fbi agents buy weapons as
powerful
as the drug cartels had they're getting
beat up
president mice also want to open the u.s
constitution once in a while
if he did he'd find a thing called the
first amendment
there's a thing called the first
amendment which is read in a way that i
think is a little excessive
from the crack epidemic of the 80s to
the crime wave of the 90s to the post-9
11 war on terror
throughout his career biden has
represented the democratic party
consensus
shifting his views to fit whatever best
serves his own political career
over his 44 years in the senate and then
as vice president
biden was a leading architect of today's
criminal justice system
which contributed to mass incarceration
and the police misconduct that
protesters are fighting back against
today
biden crime bill the biden crime bill
the biden crime bill hell we've got
crime bills coming out our ears every
major crime bill since 1976
every minor crime bill has had the name
of the democratic senator from the state
of delaware joe biden
you got a gun you commit a felony ten
years we already have it five years
minimum mandatory judge can't say you
know you had it in your pocket you never
intended to use it we're only going to
give you one year
judge has to say five years
well he wants to make it 10 or 20 or 60
i we can work that
out he wanted to remove judicial
discretion for those who quote don't
meet the middle class criteria of
susceptibility to rehabilitation
they are beyond the pale many of those
people they literally
have not been socialized they are in
jail
away from my mother your husband
our families the biden thurman violent
crime control act of 1991 would have
increased the maximum sentence for 44
crimes to include the death penalty
a wag in the newspaper recently wrote
biden has made it a death penalty
offense for everything but jaywalking
republicans one-upped biden by adding 46
capital crimes
i'm going to make it for 46 crimes biden
says make it for 51.
we're going to get tough so he proposed
then he presented the final version of
the legislation 60 new death penalties
brand new 60. there are 70
additional enhancements of penalties i.e
you go to jail longer after his
disastrous 1987 presidential campaign
biden had staged his political comeback
in part by becoming a media darling on
issues of policing and crime
and he led the fight to pass the
landmark 1994 crime bill under bill
clinton
when i wrote the original bill that
started this whole process the so-called
biden crime bill
i didn't call a liberal con fab and
write it
i didn't call any big society people and
i call the cops a democratic president
wants a hundred thousand cops a
democratic president
wants to build a 125 000 new prison
cells
that's the secret that somehow the
republicans tried to make the crime bill
tougher
i say poppycock they didn't make
anything tougher
i wrote that bill he convinced
republicans to support urban community
programs as a way to keep inner city
kids away from respectable families
i started looking at found out that this
midnight basketball and getting them
together a bunch of jive folks who are
black white and hispanic
living in their city to do you know try
to see if they can be michael jordan
when they found out they were keeping
schools open
so gangs come off streets instead of out
raping my mother marauding me
robbing the local store they're in a
gymnasium
and my daughter will be safer my wife
will be safer
my mother will be safer and i will be
safer
and i will be happy never again
should washington put politics and party
above law and order
along with several laws passed in the
80s the 1994 crime bill drove up the
local state and federal prison
populations
and it tarnished the reputations of
biden and bill clinton who signed it
into law
when biden ran for president in 2008 he
told the new york times that he knew
more people would be locked up across
the board but that it would drive down
crime in fact crime rates were already
falling when biden pushed for the
passage of the 94 crime bill
and they have continued falling as the
prison population has declined in recent
years
you ashamed of that bill not at all um
in fact i drafted the village we had
enormous success
the mass incarceration created by
biden's lock-em-up policies ripped apart
vulnerable communities and families for
a generation and the federal funding
streams and law enforcement
infrastructure it created continued to
hinder reform efforts
there are things i would change but by
and large
what it really did it restored american
cities
the younger generation now tells me how
tough things are give me a break
no no i have no empathy for it
give me a break because here's the deal
guys
we decided we were going to change the
world and we did
we did we finished the civil rights
movement to the first stage
the women's room it came to be so my
message is
get involved there's no place to hide
i'll do my job and i will take
responsibility i won't blame
others i won't traffic in fear and
division
i won't fan the flames of hate
i'll seek to heal the racial wounds that
have long plagued our country
not use them for political gain
[Music]
you